[Music]
foreign
joel peterson it is such an honor to
have you on 20-minute leaders thank you
for joining me
great to be with you michael all right
so just to get started
um because this is just way too
impressive i'm just gonna give a very
quick round down of some of the things
that you've done
so that we can start guiding the
conversation and this you are the ceo of
back then the world's largest private
commercial real estate development firm
you founded peterson partners with over
a billion dollars under management
gsb professor for many years chairman of
the board of jetblue airways
father of seven grandfather of 25 and
all
during all this time you're also on you
also launched a book on leadership did i
get that right
yeah it makes me tired to hear it teach
me your ways
i'm a young entrepreneur just starting
my path and i told you one day i hope to
be able to sit in your gsb
class as a student myself what how how
did this happen
how do you get to where you are
you know you put one foot in front of
the next and you you take opportunities
you have
goals and i remember i wrote down uh
10 goals that i had when i was in
college
and i posted them on my mirror and i had
to look at them every day when i shaved
and it reminded me to work towards them
and in the end
i achieved nine of them really yeah and
they were kind of
hard to achieve goals so i really got
an appreciation for the power of setting
goals
and writing them down i always tell my
students now always have goals but write
them in pencil
so they don't become your taskmaster
things change in life
i love just your goals but you should
always be working towards something
i love the writing in pencil part that's
uh that's really really nice
so um you exemplify what a leader is and
you exert leadership
and all sorts of different ventures that
you do from investments
to the classroom to being on the board
of a huge huge company
talk to me a little bit about leadership
and and how how do you find the balance
between
putting on these different hats on all
these different adventures
well uh being i guess i've always been
in leadership roles
ever since being captain of the safety
patrol and
student body uh president and you know
i've always
liked the process of helping people
get to an objective and what i've
learned over time is
if you can help people get where they
want to go
but might not get there without you
that's a really meaningful thing i think
it's hard to drive people
where you want them to go but i think if
you can attract people who want to go to
the same place
that you'd like to go and remove
obstacles provide incentives
get the right people belayed to each
other you can climb
really high peaks and you do that while
you're going alongside making friends
forming relationships which i'm sure
also come in handy throughout your whole
life well you've got to do that
business is a team sport family is a
team sport
and you want to have the comedy that
exists among people who like and trust
each other definitely so tell me a
little bit about this new book so you're
writing about entrepreneurial leadership
what does that even mean so um
i i've taught lead i've taught a
leadership course and an
entrepreneurship course at stanford and
i've observed that many organizations
are led by presiders some are led by
politicians
some are led by managers some are led by
administrators
and some are led by entrepreneurs right
pure entrepreneurs who know how to light
fires but may not know how to manage
them or take them to the next level
so i've really identified this class of
leaders who are really
entrepreneurial leaders they make
durable change
so they're able to make things happen
and quickly and it sticks
other people can manage it and they can
build teams and they do a bunch of
things that really create
valuable long-term success and that's
really what i'd like to see more of
interesting and you know it seems that
you can't possibly be
at so many places at the same time and
i'm sure a big part of your work is also
delegating
some of the responsibilities as you go
along to new leadership
and put your trust in you people how do
you go what is the process that you go
about in doing that how do you form this
trust
and how do you slowly put yourself away
from this
leadership position and put the trust in
others
well let me just back up and say that
what i tried to do is figure out what
are the
peers that you need to drill to get to
bedrock if you're going to erect this
edifice
that's a durable enterprise it has to
sit on a solid foundation
and the first pier is this peer of trust
you have to be trustworthy
and you have to build a high trust
culture the second thing you have to do
is you have to have a clarity about
which peak you're climbing
what is your mission do we all agree
that we're climbing the same peak and
we're provisioned and everything
so that clarity around mission is the
second thing that you have to do
which by the way is not that easy you
have to think a lot about it
i'm sure the third thing then is the one
that you're mentioning which is
getting a team together that means
sourcing the right people
interviewing them doing due diligence
onboarding them
evaluating them coaching them promoting
them demoting them and
eventually the ones that just are in the
wrong place
removing them you've got to ensure that
you've got the right team on the field
at all times so that's the third thing
that you do and then finally
if you've done all those things really
well you're ready to execute
so in this book i try to give people a
series of checklists
and mindsets and ways to go about the
most common things that entrepreneurs
run into
how do you run meetings how do you
negotiate how do you sell how do you
deal with
adversity how do you manage growth you
know these are the
very common things that every
entrepreneurial leader
and really every leader has to do it's
just that i think in today's world
it's going to be tough to be a pure
presider or a pure politician
i think you're going to have to draw on
all of these things which in the book i
call being a five
tool player interesting interesting
and you know it can't help but but face
the fact that right now
leadership is drastically changing i
think
uh due to covet 19 and there are new
challenges that every leader whether
it's a ceo or a politician or an
educator
and they face how do you see this this
change and
what are some of the different
priorities that we might have now that
we didn't necessarily have
you know three months ago well i think
the facts in the world
have changed a lot i think we don't know
a lot of things
we're still pawing around in the dark
we're not sure
we've got the denominator right in fact
we're pretty sure that the
denominator is wrong and it looks like
the numerator may not be
right and so we don't know if we have
the right policy you have to take action
and we have taken action and then you
have to adjust
and when you make changes there's no
recrimination no blame
you have to keep moving forward you have
to be optimistic so i think the leader
is going to
is is going to have to reimagine their
business
reimagine what it is they're trying to
do they've got a covenant
with investors suppliers customers
communities
and they have to emerge with the brand
they will emerge with a brand
and so what brand do they want to emerge
with and so i think that takes some
entrepreneurial thinking
and leadership but i actually think the
process is the same
in good times and bad times in order to
be a great leader
you really have to think about what are
the facts on the ground
how do we collect them how do we make
decisions before we have perfect
information
you wait until you have perfect
information you've made a decision
and it's often not a good way definitely
and you know so you
can't ignore the fact that you're the
chairman of the board of jetblue airways
and the travel industry has been taking
a pretty hard hit
perhaps the one of the hardest hits out
of any industry
so how do you approach the situation as
a leader
who's obviously obviously have to run to
continue helping lead this
this company to success but you also
have thousands of people
that are looking up to you and asking
what now what do we do
so how do you how do you even approach a
situation like that
well job one is survival and survival is
derivative of having enough liquidity
uh you're out of cash you're out of
business so you've got to make sure
you do that i think it's a little bit
like trust if you say all of a sudden
oh my gosh we have to develop trust
you've waited too long
right trust builds up a conversation at
a time a layer at a time
and it takes time to build that the same
thing with building your balance sheet
so i think you have to do that as best
you can now nobody has
enough cash in the in a capital
intensive business like the airline
business right
to survive months and months of of
really no flyers so i think you have to
you know and part of the way that we're
um gathering cash is with help from the
government
so we've got to make sure that we can
continue to
to provide uh jobs
not furlough our employees and so we're
doing all of those kinds of things but
then i think you have to be really
transparent with people
you have to confront reality you have to
describe it fairly
people will resent being fooled they'll
resent
if you don't tell them the truth so i
think you have to continue to do that
then you have to think about your brand
what is it that you provide your
customers and you're going to emerge
with a brand
yes so how you behave during this time
for example at jetblue our number one
value is safety so now there's a new uh
layer that's been added to this it's
health safety
so we need to make sure that our
passengers are in a safe place
right that may be taking temperatures
wearing baths
masks not putting anybody in the middle
seat um
already you know one thing people don't
really realize is that the air on an
airplane it's probably cleaner than it
is any place in the world
the filtering systems are great people
think you know gosh i'm going into this
metal tube with you know another 100
people that can't be clean
but it's actually filtered very
aggressively so that's probably one of
the better places
to be definitely joel you've seen
countless of entrepreneurs
successful and unsuccessful both from
the gsb
but also from your hundreds of
investments through peterson
partners give me some of your earned
secrets when you're
seeing an entrepreneur in front of you
what are some of the key things that you
observe
that you think this is somebody that he
or she will be successful in five
ten years as they climb this uphill
battle and trying to change whatever
they want to change
yeah so it's interesting when you are
involved in the venture business that's
really all you have to evaluate
right if you're making private equity
investments you can evaluate customer
less
you can uh analyze balance sheet but
uh you know a whole bunch of things but
when you're making venture investments
you're really evaluating an idea and a
human being
yeah and their character so i would say
that
those people tend to be able to see
around corners
they have a bit of a vision uh
they're kind of pure entrepreneurs they
see things that others don't see and
they see it before
because they're quite sensitized to the
market and to competitive forces and
they just have a bunch of insight
um there so i'd say that's one of the
things that they
that they really do well another is that
they uh they typically develop really
high trust relationships
with people because they have to you
know in order to raise capital
get people to uh supply them
you know in some cases they're borrowing
others brands to build their own
sure so there's a lot of things they
have to do that really are highly
dependent on trust
and i think one of the things that most
of them have
i think virtually all of them have that
we've backed is they have persistence
they don't give up they're just not
quitters they adjust
they admit mistakes they're vulnerable
uh
but they just they don't quit how do you
measure that though when somebody comes
to you for a seed or serious a even
and let's say a new entrepreneur and you
don't really have
much data to to give evidence that this
entrepreneur
will climb past the covert 19 crisis and
will continue exerting leadership
and maintain the strong brand and think
of the day after
so how do you what is the process that
you go through
perhaps with yourself to try and
evaluate this new entrepreneur let's say
that i'm coming to you
and pitching an idea the best thing is
an in-depth interview
due diligence asking questions looking
at every
time that they made a change in course
and why they did
what their thinking was you know people
who tend to be winners who tend to
succeed
like to continue to succeed and so
people who figured out how to do that
love that pattern
and they don't all of a sudden say oh
i'd like to fail today
that'd be fun i'd like that experience
so i think if you have a pattern of
success
a pattern of figuring things out pattern
of
uh changing when they need to change
and why they did it they didn't they
weren't running away from things
i always like people who are running
towards something
uh better than those who are running
away from something yeah
so i tend to listen to all those kinds
of things and then
i think one of the things that's
underestimated is do i like them
are they likable people likeable people
tend to do better than people that are
just
difficult yup well likability i think is
an underrated
uh characteristic fascinating and joel
you've seen uh you've climbed the ladder
on so many different industries you know
from
from real estate to venture to venture
capital
to now travel how do you go about
becoming an expert in these industries
because you are
a world leader in each of these and you
have to have some sort of
you know expertise to come with to be
able to to be a good leader there so how
do you
get yourself up to speed on all the bits
and pieces
and and really the high level thinking
of strategy of where this
industry perhaps is headed yeah so i
wouldn't consider myself
an expert a deep expert in any of these
areas but i
am pretty good at uh assessing people
and bringing on teams i believe business
is a team sport
and if you can assemble a world-class
team and
uh empower them you know give them the
ability to make decisions and execute on
them
you can nudge you can remove obstacles
you can provide
wisdom i've seen a lot of the movies
that they'll run into and so they may
not know how to deal with
adversity or with a difficult board
or whatever and i know how to do that so
i think if i get the right people
in place uh i can apply that to many
many different
industries definitely joel i'd like to
sort of play small mind game and think
ahead
maybe 10 20 years um
what what are some of the biggest things
you're excited about of where we're
headed
whether it is in terms of leadership or
in terms of the travel industry or real
estate or venture capital
what are some of the most exciting
things that i can look forward to
as i'm you know as i'll be 30 40 in the
workplace
so i think technology is going to impact
every business
and so i think understanding technology
big data
you know is really critical i think if
you can apply that to
how people get along what people want uh
you know people have these fundamental
needs they're going to be met in
different ways
and i think they they all need education
schooling
uh healthcare right they all want to
learn
learning is a huge need that people have
and it may come in the form of
of education online books
you know whatever tv movies
and some of that's entertainment some of
it is education
right but i think thinking about all
those things um
and seeing around corners i wish i had
the luxury of thinking i'd be around in
20 years oh i'm sure
it's not even a question joel but uh
i have to to then take it one step
further and say you know there's so much
hype
and around especially silicon valley
about all these consumer products
and a lot of these things that people
are working on that you know especi
especially in covet times
there's a very clear distinction between
essential and non-essential right we're
we're trained now to be making this
distinction on a daily basis
and i have the privilege of being a
senior associated and early stage vc
fund and we also
take very seriously this idea of is this
an essential business
or is this you know another nice to have
a
feature so how do you
then go about as sort of strategist
and be able to differentiate what
something might be nice to have or
something that is essential
well it's kind of in the eye of the
beholder as we've seen as governors have
applied different
uh measures across the country so i
don't think there is a hard and fast
rule
it's clear that people need food they
need transportation they need
shelter there are certain things that
are just core to life on the planet
there's others that i think are a little
more subtle and i wouldn't say that
they're
non-essential it's funny when uh when
people were talking about shutting folks
in
i was concerned because i wanted to come
into the office to do these kinds of
broadcasts
right somebody said are you going to get
picked up by the police for coming in
and so somebody checked it out for me
they said no online education
is essential so uh i was safe from that
so
at least according to one one uh person
assessing it this is a sin
what we're doing right now is essential
yeah other people might not think it is
but i think it's a good question i don't
think anybody has all the answers
other than there are certain things that
are absolutely
clearly essential and other things that
are frivolous and they can't take longer
to come back
right joel before we finish um i am a
young entrepreneur
i have the unique privilege of sitting
in front of you
and i have to ask you for advice for
myself so i'm on i'm starting my path
now i'm greatly enjoying my time at
stanford i love diving into deep
technology
and having the tools myself and if i
look at the sort of leader that i want
to be one day with the influence that i
want to have
you're a perfect example of that and
that's why it's very interesting for me
to hear
if you could you know give me any piece
of advice any single piece of advice
of something that i should keep in mind
as i go through this journey
over the next few decades what what is
the most important thing that i should
remember
you won't like this advice
i'm ready i'm ready so i think getting
as close to the customer
as you can and in many cases that means
selling
and i know just people don't like to
sell but
it's because they think that in selling
they're pushing product
they're like a used car salesman and
they're trying to fool people
into getting something they don't really
want or need
in fact selling is solving problems and
the closer to the customer you can get
the closer you can get to understanding
real issues
real problems and coming with creative
solutions
the better able you'll be to anticipate
the future market
to build products and services that meet
and satisfy needs
to structure deals that make sense so
i think i think i would say to and i say
this to all my young students
and not many of them like hearing it
that is that is so interesting joel i
can't believe 20 minutes are already up
one last question and i'm gonna put you
a little bit on the spot so i apologize
for not preparing you in advance
but i'd love to hear three words that
you would best describe yourself
as and this is something that i'm asking
every person that i
that i hold these conversations with
we've done almost 100 episodes so far
and it's fascinating for me to hear how
different people
within different industries are thinking
about themselves as part of this world
so what are three words that you would
best consider yourself as
or you would like others to consider you
as yeah those are two different
questions
choose either one yeah so i think of
myself as persistent
which might be stubborn i think of
myself as
kind which might be soft
and i think of myself as focused which
might be monomaniacal
it just depends on how you're looking at
it wonderful joel thank you
so so much for this time i can't wait to
hopefully be in one of your classes one
day
and i can't wait to read your new book
well thank you so much
look forward to having you in class or
at least hearing what you think about
the book
definitely take care bye bye thanks bye
you